something very emotional happened today
tim grover was in town tim grover is the
trainer of kobe bryant michael jordan he
was on the last dance he wrote a book
called relentless
and his book is coming out winning and
he did his first live interview with me
here in
boca raton and we're sitting down
talking and
one of the chapters in his book page 103
by the way we got to get his book but
one of the chapters page 103
he talks about how winning is selfish
there is no such thing as balance in
winning it just doesn't exist
and he tells the story he says one day
he's packing his bags he's getting ready
to go on the road and he's traveling
right he's packing all this stuff and
he's getting ready to go
and his five-year-old daughter looks at
him and says daddy where are you going
he says daddy's traveling and the
five-year-old daughter at the time says
why do you have to travel so much and
tim says
i have to travel a lot because daddy
travels so i can take care of you
mommy so i can put food on the table and
he says his five-year-old daughter takes
a break looks away
and then she comes back and looks his
daddy and he says when i heard these
words it love he says
it's the most difficult words i've ever
heard in my entire life
that's what he says in this book i'm
prefacing what he's saying but that's
pretty much what he's talking about with
the statement that she made to her
to him daughter looks at tim
and says hey daddy if i eat less
will you stay home more did you hear
what i just said
she said if i eat less will you stay
home more
because she's trying to say what if i
eat less you can stay with me more
often.
i asked him this question and i'm
reading his book
is sitting right in front of me you'll
see it in the interview when it comes
out on may 19th
he's emotional i'm emotional i got a
four-year-old daughter soon to be five
in the next few weeks
i got a nine-year-old and i got a
seven-year-old right and these are my
kids i love these guys
i said how did you handle that he says
it wasn't easy he says i thought about
it all day long
he said but i packed the bags and i
still went on the road because i was
traveling with michael for 15 years
that's what he was doing constantly
being with michael all the time right
he's traveling
which is all i thought about is her he
says years later i asked her i said hey
i want to explain to you why i did what
i did and the daughter says you don't
have to explain to me daddy
i know exactly why you did what you did
it's because you're going after your
dreams you're going doing this you're
doing that he says
the daughter says i'm pursuing my dreams
now and if it wasn't for you i wouldn't
have had that example
so i said how do you process this
how many of us hit the wall when we get
to a point where our daughter or
son or somebody doesn't even know
they're doing what they're doing they
give you that guilt and you hear you're
like i don't know what i'm supposed to
be doing
so then i went a little bit deeper i
said you know we're talking about kobe
and michael jordan here says yes
i said the guilt concept feeling bad
because your kids or your parents or
your wife or your husband
or somebody is that a decision somebody
else can sell you on like meaning can i
sell you on
stop feeling guilty you shouldn't feel
guilty you shall
you ought to go after your dreams he
said no
it's a decision only you can make i said
i agree never try to convince somebody
to spend less time with their wife or
their kids or anything
it's more a decision you got to make so
let me tell you a story we went to louis
bossie and we were eating there with
myself himself and sherry and we had a
great time
one of the best lunches we ever had we
got a very good connection together and
um
i said i'm gonna tell you a story about
my dad he says yeah what's that
i said when i first had my son patrick
tico he was six months old or something
like that
and i went to my dad i said dad you know
when i was living in iran with you
you would travel uh you would work
six days out of the week and you would
leave five a.m in the morning and you'd
come home at 8 30 and you expected us to
be in bed by 8 o'clock because your
standards
so we wouldn't see you but fridays in
iran friday was a
this saturday or sunday of here i said
and on sundays you were an early bird
you'd wake us up at six we'd go to
parque shahan shahi
then we'd go to church a syrian church
then we'd go to grandma's house eat her
food and we'd come back home you take a
two-hour
nap you'd listen to your music with the
headphones you would put on with the old
music he would listen to then he would
come back have dinner watch a movie and
then we'd go to sleep right
i said when i calculate the days you
spend with us in 10 years
that we lived in iran together when you
and mom were still together
it's 52 days a year times 10 520 days
out of 3650 days
you had 3 650 days in 10 years but you
only saw us 520 days
did it bother you do you ever regret
that as a father
without any hesitate i don't know what
he's going to tell me like i'm 33 years
old and i'm asking him this question
no hesitation he says no regrets i said
dad don't tell me this because you're
protecting your ego
do you feel like you regret any of it
like you wish you would have worked less
to spend more time with us
he says zero he said come on that you
can't tell me that
he says i'm telling you zero so now he's
getting past i said why he says what is
my job as a father
is it my job as a father to teach you
and raise you to be strong so you can be
independent without having to rely on
anybody else meaning you can't stand on
your own two feet and you can go out
there and take your own family and take
care of isn't that the job of a father
yes how are you doing
i said i'm independent i said then i did
my job right
he says i don't regret any of it he says
i enjoyed every minute i had with you
guys i had so much fun with you on
paulette
i said that's very good to hear because
as a man now that i'm getting through
the next phase
i like hearing that from my own father
but i said i want to say something to
you as well he says what's that
i said it's crazy that i'm 33 thinking
about this i'm 42 now when i talked
about
talking about this i was 33. i said i'm
33 sitting here thinking
about this with you and i also don't
have any regrets that you weren't there
he says what do you mean i said to me it
was the normal thing
everybody in iran you're working i said
i saw other dads that weren't workers
and sometimes they didn't have money and
they were going through challenges my
daddy
worked his ass off to provide how lucky
i am to have a father that provided for
me
i said i wanted you to know from me that
i also have no guilt for you
you're the best thing that ever happened
to me as a father i love you and i
appreciate your example
we had a very unique moment together
right i got kids i'm kind of going
through it and my dad and i
have a very good relationship so let me
let me wrap this up so you kind of get
the idea what the point
so tim says pat you know why i didn't
feel guilty he says what
he says if you're away from your family
or you're at a bar getting drunk
you're a bad dad if you're doing that
because your way you're not you don't
have more of authority why would you not
spend time with your kids over drinking
and getting
a going to a bar why would you not want
to be there and start going and hanging
out and just doing other kind of stuff
why wouldn't you want to spend more time
with your kids right
he didn't say you're bad that the point
he's trying to make is the fact that hey
you have options why not go and spend
time more with your kids
he said but if you're away from your
kids you better make
it count and you better win that is the
only way
they're forgiven they'll forgive you if
you use that time to win
this is why kobe's kids loved him this
is why
michael's kids this is why anybody that
lives and performs at the highest level
at least the kids sit there and say even
though daddy was away even though mommy
was away
at least he or she used at times wisely
to win
then when there's experiences you remind
them look where we are this is because
mommy and daddy
worked very hard so you know i was going
through this i know
i i did a video a few weeks ago about
guilt and i think it's a topic that a
lot of entrepreneurs and executives
struggle with i wanted to kind of share
with you what happened today because
this was something that i shared with a
few all day today i've been sharing this
story because it's an incredible part of
the book that i think everybody needs to
read about
and hopefully it makes kind of an impact
for you
as it did for me because i do know as an
entrepreneur executive driven person at
one point
you're gonna hit that wall where that
guilt's gonna be felt
and anybody and everybody can give you
advice i can tell you what to do
but at the end of the day you have to
make that decision yourself
i made my choice to go after my vision
because
long term i'd like to be able to set up
a position
where these kids are in business with me
in many many different ways they don't
have to do
the same thing all three of them but i'd
like long term for our family
to be closer simply because the
decisions that he's making
today so having said that look i think
to the right person this is a video that
can probably impact your life and start
thinking about some of the bigger
decisions you need to make in your life
but if you didn't see
my first interview with tim grover the
author of relentless and a news book
coming out called winning
click over here to watch the interview i
have a feeling
you're going to take a lot away from
this interview take care everybody
bye-bye